if Donald Trump launches airstrikes
against the Assad regime in Syria to
punish it for using chemical weapons
Britain must participate
there are many naysayers among the
populace left and right who share more
in common than they'd care to admit but
a failure to act would allow a new
precedent to be set that it's too
horrific to imagine if Theresa May
follows the recently invented convention
of seeking Parliament's approval for
action she could lose but there is no
law that requires government to ask MPs
as our commander in chief she can alone
authorize military force and she should
do so this would place us firmly in a
broad Western alliance
whereas our absence would further
isolate us and be seen as a sign of
global weakness we stand at a crossroads
Britain must uphold international law by
deterring the use of chemical weapons
anywhere at any time getting Iraq wrong
doesn't mean we simply cower from our
duty while civilians are gassed with
impunity
we must act do you not well imagine that
we are we are in a very dangerous
position at the moment not just we but
but the whole thing is seems dangerous
to me that almost for the first time
since I was a kid in the Cuban Missile
Crisis you feel this could escalate into
something very serious and I'm not sure
I mean let me just show you what Trump
actually said here's his tweet he said
Russia vows to shoot down any and all
missiles fired at Syria
get ready Russia because they will be
coming nice and new and smart you
shouldn't be partners with a gas killing
animal who kills his people and enjoys
it now I don't not sure I want to be
partner with him that's my problem that
you might be right that if it happens we
may have to join in but I don't think
anyone has thought through what are the
implications in this and what could
happen and it seems to me the time for
us to have action is not now it's three
or four years ago
but do you not do you not think we have
to stand against chemical weapons
becoming the northern war you know for
decades for decades we have fought to
not have that is the case and you know I
get why and I completely get what you're
saying I get why after Iraq people don't
want us to become involved in someone
else's war I completely get that but we
can't let memories of what happened
there
paralyzed future foreign policy you know
we have as a country you know we have to
act in defense of vital principles you
know of human rights of law and order we
can't let you know that the pictures
this week of those kids lying on a cold
hospital floor was white foam coming out
of their mouths choking and dying we
can't stand idle baggage I'll show you
exactly what Carol's refer to let's have
a look at this footage viewers may find
this distressing but here we see the
children and the results of a chemical
the alleged chemical attack on children
and I just think simply Greg that though
it is a difficult decision one must
never go to any form of military action
with too easily if you if you see this
footage and precisely it's a callous
point that we cannot do is allow for
precedents to be set in warfare that
this normalizes the use of chemical
weapons hold on just to respond to your
point cuz you asked me a question at the
beginning that normalizes the use of
chemical weapons
I am worried and it's for that same
concern that I opposed the Iraq war and
always have opposed the Iraq war but
what I worry about is that in 2013 we
had the option to try and stop this
precedent being set in Syria it went to
Parliament Parliament rejected it and
then Obama's infamous LED line was
breached as a result and what we have
seen is two more alleged chemical
attacks in Syria by the Syrian regime
since then and so I worry that already
it's becoming a norm what do you do the
stops on doing it again if we've done it
before and they did it again what I mean
I don't see a strategy here I just see a
thirteen can I show you a clip from the
Commons which I'm sure you all remember
from the last time Parliament debated
this dilemma is I see of whether to take
military action in Syria here's David
Cameron we can be as certain as possible
that when we have a regime that has used
chemical weapons on 14 occasions that is
most likely responsible for this
large-scale attack that if nothing is
done it will conclude that it can use
these weapons again and again and on a
larger scale and with impunity we're not
going to be supporting a government
motion which was briefed this morning at
setting our in-principle decision to
take military action that would be the
wrong thing to do I think that that the
dilemma that you see playing itself out
there is still the dilemma today and you
imagine there's not really anything you
said that I disagree with but there are
a few things I have a problem with and
the first is that I don't think that the
kind of action that trees our maker take
using her probative powers to launch
military strikes against chemical
weapons would be enough to make a
meaningful difference in the long term I
think it would need to be part of as
Greg said a broader strategy and a
better thought out approach this isn't
my worry about Trump that chemical
weapons quite rightly are this emotional
trigger that makes everyone want to act
the reality is that Assad has been
killing Syrian civilians including
children for the last seven years
hundreds of thousands have died this is
not a new problem we have introduced a
new form we need to act not based on
what makes Britain look good and strong
but based on what is going to help
deescalate this crisis not escalate it
and I really fear that pouring more
force into that region without a proper
plan is actually going to have the
reverse effect and if we all want the
best thing for Syrian people I think we
need to be I'm very happy that we are
debating this with a heavy heart because
you know no one should sort of take any
military action so easily but you know
we've played enough clip so I'm just
gonna read to you what the prime
minister said they're just the first
line all the indications are that the
Syrian regime was responsible all the
indications are there is a very strong
field of thought but as he was so close
to taking that part of Syria why the
hell did he need to deploy chemical
weapons is it actually a reverse by Isis
who will responsible anything to
promptings so we've got to be very very
careful cause I don't think we do
anything until we get inspectors in
there I really don't and then what are
you seeking to do magic is it a wrap
across the knuckles because we did it a
year I'm sorry the u.s. tomahawks did it
in a year ago it achieved absolutely
nothing
if it is I said because you can are you
talking about something bigger than that
because be very very cautious because we
do something bigger than that likely
Russians will get that's real once you
start killing Russians by doing nothing
we emboldened Russian intervention we
emboldened it happen first of all first
of all the inspector the Russians
already have secured the area so if the
inspectors get there and they want to
get there they will get there under
russian military supervision and that's
part of the problem that the entire area
that was struck duma well sealed off by
the syrian regime in the russians we can
never really get to that area at the
affected area without the interference
of the russian military i having already
taken place and to your other point i
mean look this is already escalated i
really do appreciate that people are
worried about escalation but we have to
caveat that with another point that the
syrian regime the iranian it's Iranian
and Hezbollah backers and it's Russian
backers have been escalating the crisis
for many years now worried and cautious
which finally you're out of step with
the public the times did twenty percent
of people yes which is why I don't think
I'm my problem with it is if you just
what do you do and where does it take
you to yeah what's the endgame mumbling
of a few airports and then you go back
to now nobody wants to do this without
strategies it's worthless point of
course we need a strategy we need to
learn lessons and we need to make sure
they're implemented that's really
difficult because because we I think
everyone would agree it's better to have
a strategy what is the strategy going to
be are we talking about regime change
ultimately who what do we have to offer
this a better alternative an asset yeah
you know who is going to end up in
control of Syria and what is that going
to mean for the region and the world and
these are the dilemmas here that there
is no good option and I I can't see in
the absence of some kind of negotiated
future that would be viable what we need
taking down a side or striking a you
know the idea of
taking out the chemical weapons
capability is very attractive but there
are so many problems with ethnic that
you can strike Russians you can escalate
the question remember we've been here
before when when the Russians assured us
that they had 100% removed the Syrian
regime's chemical capabilities so we've
already tried the duromatic group we've
already accepted their assurances
clearly that wasn't true now Senator
Kerry at the time in a Secretary of
State assured the world that the
Russians would implement that enforce it
which is why Obama allowed his redline
to be transgressed in the way he did so
my case is we've tried everything we've
tried to de-escalate we've tried to
appease the Russian the Iranian well the
last time the inspectors did go in and
they did say it was a chemical chemical
attack but they weren't asked to
apportion blame which is understandable
cuz they need to be neutral about saying
we've been saying we've got to do this
and not ask you for a regime changes
want to make that clear I'm like what
are you I need a very clear deterrent
because Putin and this is the last thing
I'll say is trying to change the rules
of the game he's trying to make it
acceptable in the international order to
use chemical weapons and he did it right
here in our country in Salisbury so we
cannot let that presently we all
probably - we're partly to blame for
this because in 2013 you quite rightly
said we had the chance to do this as did
the US and had we acted back then we
wouldn't have had to act quite so
aggressively back then but perhaps it
would have stopped some of the chemical
atrocities that have already happened
but it didn't it emboldened Russia and
it emboldened a sad because he he felt
invincible so so had we had we all of us
acted back then had the world acted back
then and the UN is never going to be
able to work because Russia was always
gonna block any vote so we know we can
say we don't know what we're gonna do
but can we sit idly by and let this
people Brookwood me but what is the end
game but it's easy to sit here and say
yes we've got to do so let's reassure
you that actually that so the five
different quarters have actually said
there's been an attack twice last
Saturday at the 7th of April at 4
o'clock and 732 attacks and reports of
that come from the the violent violation
documentation Center which is an NGO
World Health Organization affiliates as
well as a Syrian American
let the union of men another let's
assume let's assume it was fired by
their buyer side which I'm quite well
bleak right
what what's the endgame what do you do
changes this unless you're gonna have a
gene join it was fired by asset if you
accept that then the question should be
how do we respond not whether we respond
if you accept that a regime has dropped
chemical weapons on its own people we
have no choice but to respond
[Laughter]